There's the music. Come on down to the water, little ones. I've a question before the story. When you've done something really wrong, and a small voice says just RUN — what happens if you do? Hold that one close.
Here's a thing I've learned over a good long life. When you slip up and want to bolt, you can run as fast as your legs will carry you. But God doesn't give you up that easy. He keeps the way back open — and that's the only road that takes you home. Listen close. The answer's in the story.
Now, this happened on a bright, splashy morning down by the creek. And nobody loved it more than one young river otter named Rex, who came barreling down the muddy bank and landed with the happiest splash you ever heard. Rex slides for the pure joy of it — for no reason but glad. A true otter thing.
Oh — wow — okay, the mud is cold on top and WARM underneath. New favorite thing! And — that smell, the green wet morning smell — ohh, that one too, add it to the list. I've found eleven good things already and the sun's barely up. I love this creek so much I could just about BURST.
Watch — watch this one, I do it again — up the bank, turn around, and... WHEE — down! Oh, that's the good slide, that's the GREAT slide, the bottom's all slick today. I could do this until I'm a hundred. Somebody time me. Somebody count how many.
ELEVEN good things before breakfast! A creature of pure APPETITE for life! Yesterday it was twelve, the day before, FIFTEEN. At this rate the boy will run out of things to love by LUNCH.
And up the bank was Bongo the bear cub. For three whole days he'd been building a little boat — real reeds and river-grass, a bend at the front, big enough to float a snack across the pond. And that morning, it was done.
There it is. It floats! It actually floats and it didn't fall apart and I didn't sit on it this time! Three days, and — okay, I got this. I really, actually got this. Hey, Rex — come see — I MADE something. It's the best thing I ever made.
A BOAT?! You made a — okay that is the BEST thing, sorry mud, sorry green smell, you've been replaced, the BOAT wins — Bongo, can I see it can I touch it can I ride it, I'm gonna ride it, watch this, watch, I'm coming in HOT —
Rex — buddy, no, you do not RIDE a brand-new boat at full speed, that's not a maiden voyage, that's a crash test — okay he's not listening, he's already sliding, why does nobody run the numbers first.
And here's the part I wish I could tell different. Rex came in too fast, the way joy does sometimes. There was a slip, a splash, and a small, terrible CRUNCH of bending reeds —
...Oh no. The front bit. It bent all the way over. ...It's broke. ...My boat's broke.
I — no — no, please, I didn't mean to, it was an accident, I came in too fast, I always come in too fast, I'm so sorry, Bongo — I'm sorry.
And then Rex did the thing he'd never had to learn NOT to do. The hard thing was right there — turn around, own it. But he looked at the broken boat, and Bongo's face, and he couldn't. So he went into the water, and he swam. Away.
Wait — where's he going — hey, REX? Did he just — he LEFT? He left the broke boat and just — okay that's not a plan, that's the OPPOSITE of a plan, you can't engineer your way out by leaving, that's not how leaving works.
He FLEES! The otter FLEES down the creek like a hero in the second act of a TRAGEDY! ...Should somebody go after him? ...I would, but I have just remembered I cannot swim. I shall narrate from here.
...You're a parrot, Garingo. You can fly.
Um... I noticed something. He didn't leave because he doesn't care. ...Did you see his face? He left BECAUSE he cares. That's a different kind of running.
...He didn't have to run. ...I wasn't even gonna yell. I don't yell. I was just gonna say 'it's okay, accidents happen, help me fix it.' ...That's all. He didn't even wait to hear it.
I even wrote 'Bongo's Boat' on the side. In MUD. ...Well. Now it says 'Bongo's Boa.' The 't' fell in the creek. ...It's all falling in the creek today.
...He can swim fast. ...He can't swim faster than what he's carrying, though. Nobody can. ...That boat's going with him whether he likes it or not.
Now, far down the creek, where the water runs quick, Rex swam. And the whole way, he told himself a story.
It's fine. It's totally fine. Boats break all the time, that's — that's basically what boats DO, everybody knows that. Bongo's probably not even mad. He's probably already forgot. I'll fix it later. I'll definitely fix it later, when it's less... when it's later. Just keep swimming. Swimming's good. Swimming away is great.
And on, and on — until the creek ran white and loud over the rocks, and there was no more creek to swim.
Whoa — whoa, hey, slow down, water — okay that's the rapids, that's a LOT of rapids, I can't — there's no more creek. ...There's no more creek to swim.
...Okay. So this is the end of the creek. The actual end. I swam the WHOLE thing — every bend, every fast bit — fast as I could go. ...And it's still here. The boat-thing. The Bongo-thing. It's right here in my chest, heavy as a stone, same as it was on the bank. ...I swam a whole creek and I didn't lose it. Not even a little. ...Huh. You really, truly can't out-swim it.
And back at the bank, Bongo didn't shout, and he didn't sulk. He just knelt down and started gathering the broken reeds into a little pile — leaving room to mend them. The door stayed open.
Professor Hoot here, with a fact that is entirely true. A salmon is born in a small stream, and then it swims away — out, and out, all the way to the wide and open sea, where it lives for years and grows up strong. And then, when its time comes, it finds its way back to the very same stream it was born in. How? It carries the way home INSIDE it. Partly a built-in feel for the pull of the earth — a kind of compass, you might say, for the long way back — and partly the remembered SMELL of its own home water, kept all those years, which guides it to the very stream. However far it roams, the way back was always there, and it never once lost it. A fact, children. Good day.
Mm. The way home, carried inside. ...There's an old story I keep close — about a man who ran from a hard thing, out onto the deep water, and learned God doesn't give up that easy. But watch Rex first.
Now, Rex didn't have to be told the way back — an otter never forgets his own water. He turned at the rapids and swam home, slower this time, and came up at the bank dripping and quiet. He sat by Bongo, the bright gone from his voice, and said,
...Bongo. ...I broke your boat. The one you worked on three whole days. ...And then I did the worse part. I didn't run because I didn't care about it. ...I ran because I did. ...I couldn't look at your face and see the thing I did sitting right there on it. So I just... swam off. Like that would make it not true.
...And here's the thing nobody tells you. The whole time I was swimming away from it — it came with me. The whole way. It didn't get smaller. ...I swam the entire creek, Bongo, all the way to the white water. And the sorry was right there the whole time, sitting in my chest. You really can't out-swim it.
Rex. ...When you swam off down the creek, old friend — did the wrong thing get any smaller behind you?
...No. ...Not even a little. It only got heavier the farther I went. ...The only thing that ever made it lighter was turning around. And coming back here. To say it to your actual face.
...Rex. Look at me. ...I wasn't ever gonna be mad. Accidents happen — I sit on my OWN boats, remember? I just wanted you to stay. That's the whole thing. You don't have to swim anywhere. The way back was open the whole time. ...You just have to turn around and use it.
And you know what my grandpa-bear used to say? That's how God does it too. You mess up and you run, and God doesn't give up and chase you off — He keeps the way back open, and He comes and finds you, and He gives you another go. A second time. ...So. Second time. You and me. Let's fix my boat.
...You'd let me help fix it? After I — ...okay. Okay, yes. And I mean this one for real, more than the mud and the smell and all eleven of the others — my new favorite thing is a second chance. ...Hand me a reed. I'm gonna learn to come in slow.
Oh thank goodness — okay, GREAT, you're back, I have SO many boat ideas, I had like seven while you were gone — no, you know what, no. ...You two fix it. The slow way. ...I'll just hold the reeds. That's me helping. With my hands. Quietly. Look at me being quiet.
Okay — bend this one back, gentle, see? It doesn't have to be perfect. Mine never is. ...There. Push the front bit straight. ...Hey. Hey, look at that. It's already looking like a boat again.
...I'm gonna name it. Can I name it? ...'The Second Chance.' That's its name now. A boat that broke and got fixed and floats anyway. ...Best boat on the whole creek. I mean it.
...And Bongo? Next time I find a new favorite thing, I'm gonna stop, and look where my feet are going first. ...That's the part I missed. The looking. ...I'm really glad you waited for me.
Now, that afternoon, the boat floated again — crooked at the front, but floating. We sat in the warm grass, and Bongo said it first, and plain.
I think it's this. When you do something wrong, the running-away feels like the easy part. But it's not. It's the heavy part. The brave part — the part that actually makes it lighter — is turning around and coming back and saying 'I did it, and I'm sorry.' And then helping fix it. That's the part that works.
And I'll tell you what it taught ME — and I learned it the long way, the whole-creek way, so listen. You cannot out-swim a thing you did. It just comes along, sitting in your chest, getting heavier with every bend. But here's the part that saved me: the way back doesn't close. Not ever. You only have to turn around and use it. ...That's the best thing I found all day. Turning around.
BEHOLD — the otter who ran to the ENDS of the creek, and returned a HERO of the heart! ...I shall compose an EPIC. ...A short one. ...Possibly just the boat part. ...The point is — coming back is the bravest voyage there IS. I have decided this. It is now FACT.
And here's the old line I kept till the end. It's in the Bible — a book called Jonah, chapter three, verse one. A man named Jonah was given a hard thing to do, and didn't want it. So he ran — out onto the deep sea.
But God didn't give him up. When Jonah went down into the deep water, God sent a great fish to keep him safe and bring him back to dry land — not to scare him. And once Jonah was back on dry ground, God came to him again. Here's the very line the Bible uses — listen close to how it ends:
And the word of the LORD came unto Jonah the second time, saying.
That word — saying — means God had more to tell him: a second chance at the very thing he ran from. So when you've done wrong and run, God doesn't write you off. He keeps the way back open and comes to you again. So don't run — turn around. Say the true thing — I did it, I'm sorry — and make it right. You can't out-swim it. And you don't have to.
And then — up from the reeds came the Mudpuppy brothers, Splish, Splash, and Splosh. Splosh started,
Today on Mudpuppy Minutes, we will explain... what you are SUPPOSED to do when you mess something UP!
Easy. You blame a rock. There's ALWAYS a rock. 'Who broke the thing?' 'That rock.' The rock never argues. I have blamed nineteen rocks this week and not ONE of them told on me. Flawless.
No no — wait. Isn't it... you go BACK? And you say 'oops, that was me, I'm sorry,' and you help fix it? And then it's, like... over? And then they're still your friend?
Oh NO — no, that's FAR too brave, that can't be right, that's WAY too easy. Going BACK? Saying SORRY? Out of the question. You MOVE. You find a brand-new pond, change your name, get a little hat, start a whole new life. I am currently on my fourth pond and my third name. Call me Gerald.
Ooh, Gerald, yes. OR — even better — if nobody actually SAW you do it... then it didn't happen. That's just science. No witness, no oopsie. The thing un-happens. I un-happen things ALL day.
Wait — was it actually the going-back-and-saying-sorry thing? The brave easy one?
...Nah. Gerald's right. New pond.
Mudpuppies, mudpuppies — we have solved it. When you mess up, blame a rock and move to a new pond. Case closed!
Here's the real of it, little ones. You don't blame a rock, and you surely don't move ponds. Splash had it for a blink: when you mess up, you go back, say the true thing — I did it, I'm sorry — and help fix it. That's the whole brave secret. The frogs may keep their hats.
And as the light went gold, Rex and Bongo set the little crooked boat on the water once more, and it floated just fine. Rex came in slow this time — careful, and proud of it. Be well, little ones. And when you slip — and you will — don't swim off. Turn around. The way back's right where you left it.
See you next time, somewhere in Shiloh Creek.